immer noch verkatert aber 2021 endlich
ich will ehrlich sein dieses jahr könnte
ich gut auf eine pandemie verzichten
also vielleicht nächstes jahr wieder
aber sonst erst mal nicht das tier das
geile an diesem jahr
man ist einfach nur froh das ist nicht
2020 ist 2021 ist der joe biden unter
den jahren oder im januar ist es ja
direkt soweit donald schon haben
verlässt das weiße haus das warten an
einigen anklagen auf ihn wegen betrugs
steuerhinterziehung geldwäsche und
sexuellen missbrauch also einfach ein
klassischer mittwoch wenn man sich mal
gehen lassen es kann also sein dass er
nicht mehr so viel dazu kommt golf zu
spielen wie noch zuvor in einer amtszeit
da stand er über 300 mal auf dem
golfplatz über 300 mal wie gut es donald
trump eigentlich im golf spielen
ich denke dort schauen will in vier
jahren noch mal präsident werden einfach
damit er wieder zeit zum golfspielen hat
grundsätzlich nicht verkehrt wenn man
als politiker viel golf spielt kommt
drauf an was man besser kann golf oder
politik und da würde ich jetzt mal
umgesehen sagen an die scheuer ist
ingolf besser mitarbeiter ist er sogar
der union peinlich deswegen wird dieses
jahr an die scheuer endlich nicht mehr
verkehrsminister sein letztes jahr ist
er endgültig klar geworden wir alle
müssen mindestens 500 millionen euro
zahlen wegen seiner pkw maut für
ausländer die maut kommt nicht
aber die firmen die die vorbereitet
haben kriegen die entschädigungen weil
eine scheiße ich dachte ich kann mir
keinen menschen auf der welt vorstellen
der das nicht geil findet und dann hat
der europäische gerichtshof gesagt doch
wir sind die europäische union
also ich meine in deutschland könnte ich
sagen ja wir importieren gerne billige
arbeitskräfte aber die autobahn für euch
ausländer die sind lava und da war an
die scheuer völlig überrascht dass ihn
außerhalb von bayerischen wirtshäusern
leute manchmal nur so mittel finden
spannende frage ist
jetzt wer wird neuer verkehrsminister
oder verkehrsminister hin wer übernimmt
es abends 2001 haben sie macht ja genug
sei ich sag mal so wenn jetzt aber wenn
jetzt hier dieser stock verkehrsminister
würde der winter vom start an besser
sein als aldi scheuer dieser stock gibt
ja keine 500 millionen für nichts aus
dieser stock macht kein bußgeld katalog
und zieht ihn dann zurück dieser stock
träumt nicht von flugtag sie träumt gar
nicht geschlagen ein überschlag ist
fantastisch warum haben sie nicht schon
viel früher für diesen stock entschieden
die muss ja auch nicht impfen der selber
gesund denn es wird hier jetzt gm doch
impfstoff als kriegt man die leute die
den impfstoff kreiert haben haben ja
monate lang überlegt was rein soll also
bei deiner zahnpasta da kannst du sagen
man weiß ja nicht was drin ist und die
benutze trotzdem aber ist jetzt nicht so
als hätten die sowie virologe im kreis
gesessen und sich gedacht weißt du was
du geben einfach mal alles rein was wir
im labor finden wo ich habe hier noch
ein brief von zu hause wie dritten wir
da ähnlich hier mal mit dazu und mal
ganz ehrlich würde es dir helfen wenn
die leute sagen was drin ist also ich
meine ihr habt doch schon mit weniger
nutzen eurem körper mehr geschadet
hier weißt du noch artig beim
polterabend bei marianne weiß eben nicht
mehr weil der kurzen frist um halb
sieben um halb acht und hat es ja am
nächsten tag herausgefunden dass der
jägermeister wohl schlecht geworden war
niemand sagt nehmt den impfstoff weil
ihr euch ewige jugend schenkt alle
experten sagen lasst euch impfen damit
wir weitere wellen verhindern nachdem
das mit dem lockdown leid ich kann so
gut funktioniert hat damit ihr nicht
mehr locker und 3 und 4 wieder sagen
dass ich gar nicht kommen sehen
wie gesagt mal wird genügsam ich freue
mich sogar auf die bundestagswahl in
diesem jahr robert habeck stelle auf
jeden fall als kanzler zur verfügung
falls ihr euch fragt robert habeck hat
sich nämlich gefragt er meinte man müsse
sich selbst überprüfen ob man glaubt man
im traum was man will
diesen plan habe ich und deshalb ist die
antwort ja ich würde diese prüfung für
mich bestehen ja diese prüfung würde ich
für mich bestehen da habe ich zum
letzten mal in der mündlichen
abiturprüfung in mathe gesagt und ich
sag mal so da gab es abweichende
einschätzung die grünen könnten jetzt
also zum ersten mal zusammen mit dem
ehemaligen feind der cdu regieren die
grünen sind wieder prenzlauer berg du
denkst immer noch bürgerlicher gebe es
nicht und da kommt robert habeck und
baut ein suv carport in den bioladen
robert habeck seine mission den
gesichtslosen ein gesicht geben
der autor robert habeck hat sich schon
früh zu allen seiten eine
koalitionsoption offen gelassen man muss
nur den titel seiner bücher angucken
hier zum beispiel kleine helden große
abenteuer
das passt ja seit zehn jahren zur
geschichte der spd oder sind wir hier
patriotismus ein linkes plädoyer das war
wahnsinn dass ich gleich cdu und
linkspartei mit drin oder hier ist wer
wagt beginnt was ist es genau fdp
natürlich die fdp war immer mal wieder
mal also entweder nicht regieren oder
regieren mit tolerierung der nazis und
dann beginnen sie immer wieder von vorne
die fdp ist ewiger trainer zu dem film
den es nicht gibt ja oder hier das auch
geil unter dem gully liegt das meer
klingt nach einer großen verschwörung
erzählung würde ich sagen dass holt die
impfgegner abend falls ihr immer noch
nicht überzeugt seid das 2001 fand sich
spielspaß spitze wird das kindergeld
wird um 15 euro angehoben gl
meine frage an alle eltern was macht ihr
mit dem wrestler vom krieger geld übrig
bleibt
da kann man sich zb dieses kinderbuch
kaufen
fuchs der knapp acht leute die bücher
von robert habeck kauften kauft auch
dass cages aber vielleicht können wir
uns dann wird man ja ich sehe gerade
leider 16 euro aber kann ich euch gerne
ausleihen
vielleicht können wir uns für dieses
jahr vornehmen wenn es einen neuen
lockdown geben sollte können wir da
nicht zum dritten mal nudeln und
klopapier bunkern als wären wir die
ersten menschen einmal als deutschland
nicht peinlich sein wird es gehen wenn
ihr unbedingt bunkern müsst warum ich
tickets für kulturveranstaltungen ab
früher endlich wieder festivals konzerte
theater kino kommen wir die literatur
museen also wir nämlich so ich bin
sicher nicht zu hause und denkt auch mal
an die kleinen lernen und künstlerinnen
und künstler die es besonders hart
getroffen hat ja ich rede von mir eine
kleine aufmerksamkeit da lassen einfach
so per paypal vielleicht auch ohne
scheiß es wäre furchtbar wenn diese
krise nur mainstream künstler überleben
würden was hast du denn gegen den
mainstream der feier kistler
ich hab geist gegen mainstream ich bin
eher für abwechslung ja natürlich aber
jeder fängt mal klein an natürlich das
heißt wenn man die kleinen nicht
unterstützt ist hängt keine namen
stell dir das mal vor es gibt nur noch
musik die es heute gibt ein leben lang
ich muss die charts von heute noch 50
jahre lang gehören das wird ein mega
schnell er den song hier fanden die
meisten menschen vor 50 jahren auch das
war einer der hits des jahres
deswegen ist mein vorsatz ich
unterstütze klein
ich bin eine veranstaltung die ich nie
im leben gesucht hätte hier mittelalter
festival
laudan um im schlaf an der knatter ich
komm besucher auf ist ein richtig guter
musiker aber er spielt songs von peter
maffay weil wir in rom gebeten haben
weil es witzig ist für euch jetzt ist
zeit mal ein bisschen was zurückzugeben
und den kanal zu abonnieren und auch die
anderen videos anzugucken
vielen dank danke dann gereicht man ist
ja immer noch mal ein video rufe danke
danke